baptisé Madeleine braise pour rendre
hommage à la première femme médecin de
France la nouvelle maison médicale de
Villennes-sur-Seine s'étend sur deux
étages et a pour objectif d'accueillir
une trentaine de professionnels de santé
c'est une demande de défilé noir et
c'est une demande d'ailleurs générale
parce que nous savons les problèmes
qu'il y a de de problèmes sanitaires en
France et la recherche des généralistes
et nous avons la chance
cavillen-sur-seine nous ayons dans cette
maison médicale 5 médecins généralistes
et la chance que nous avons également
c'est de bénéficier donc de deux
médecins qui sont maître de stage
c'est-à-dire qu'ils forment les médecins
du futur sous forme d'un terme et on
aura la chance donc de disposer d'un
interne qui sera installé également dans
un bureau ici à la maison médicale donc
il apprendra son métier sur le tas dans
la maison médicale ici nous avons plus
de collègues autour
et je pense que ça rassure aussi
beaucoup de gens d'avoir tout tout en un
on va dire c'est un travail en équipe
dans notre secrétaire qui est qui est
avec nous depuis très longtemps organise
un peu le flux des patients
renseigne sur les rendez-vous etc donc
c'est une aide importante quatre
infirmières disposent d'un cabinet pour
assurer des vaccinations ou des soins
auprès des patients ainsi que certains
spécialistes qui sont déjà disponibles
cette maison médicale sur deux étages et
ici à l'étage nous avons principalement
donc sur une face
déclinésithérapeute des orthophonistes
des ostéopathes psychomotrices motrices
également et sur l'autre face sur
l'autre du bâtiment nous disposons
également de cabinets qui sont mis à la
disposition de spécialistes et nous
avons notamment donc un cardiologue et
nous venons de signer un bail également
donc avec une pédiatre les deux
pharmacies de Villennes-sur-Seine ont
également fusionné se retrouvent
dorénavant au rez-de-chaussée du
bâtiment les locaux sont très
fonctionnels c'est vraiment enfin
correspondre à notre attente au niveau
au
niveau exercice par rapport à notre
nouvelle mission on peut tout faire
qu'on est un local orthopédie qu'on est
un local de vaccination qu'on est de
l'espace pour accueillir qu'on puisse
avoir des postes assis pour accueillir
nos nos personnes à mobilité réduite ça
c'est plutôt très confortable la maison
médicale cherche encore un dermatologue
un rhumatologue et deux nouveaux
kinésithérapeutes pour compléter son
offre de soins